Google has shared with us the best way
to prompt VO 3.1. And in the video
today, I'm going to show you how to do
this simply so that you can start
creating the very best prompts for your
videos. In the video, you're going to
learn the fivepart formula for directing
the scene. This is cinematography shot
composition, which is the camera angle
and the position, the movement. It's the
subject, which is the main character or
focal point in the video. action, which
is what is the subject doing? How is it
moving in the video? Then you've got
context and setting. This is the
environment and the background or the
time of day. And finally, style and
ambiance. The overall aesthetic, mood,
lighting or feeling of the scene. So,
before we get into how to do this prompt
formula and create really good prompts
with it, let's show you how you can
access Google V3.1. The first place you
can access VO3.1 is in Google Flow and
you can just type this into Google and
it will take you straight here. Now you
will have to sign up to use it but then
you get access to text to video and
frames to video inside Google Flow. So
the other way that I use VO3.1 is in
Higsfield AI. Now, this is brilliant
because you could get access to Sora 2,
Google V3.1, Clean 2.5 Turbo, and a
whole lot of amazing software. You also
have a lot more power inside this. You
can use the frames option, start to end
frame, the ingredients option to add in
your own images, and you've got
prompting and different options to
change the quality and multi-shot mode.
It's definitely worth checking this out
if you're going to use VO3.1 a lot
moving forward.
So, first up, we have cinematography and
shot composition. This is the camera
angle and the position or the movement
of the character or the scene. You can
control this in many different ways,
like a medium shot, a slow zoom, a low
camera angle, creating different moods
and feelings in your video. Adding
specific camera angles and movements can
really make your video dynamic. Next up
is the subject. This is the main
character or the focal point that you
want to focus on in the video. And it's
best to describe this in detail. The
better you describe the look of your
character and the details you add in,
the better the result you'll get. When
you've created the main character, you
want to look at action. This is an
important step to really show what the
subject is doing in the video, and you
can control this with this part of the
prompt. A great way to do this is to
really describe the way the subject is
moving around the scene. Next up, you've
got context and setting. This is
important because it describes the
environment or the world that you're
creating with the video. Also, this is
describing the background, the time of
day, weather, if it's bright or if it's
dark. You could really set the scene
with this part of the prompt. Finally,
you've got style and ambience. This is
the overall aesthetic. It really follows
on nicely from the environment, just
really digging deeper into the mood and
the lighting. You can describe things
like the light and how you want it to
look. And if you want things to be
cinematic, ultra real, or if you want it
to be a cartoon, I'm really excited to
announce that today's video has been
sponsored by Skillshare. On Skillshare,
you have access to thousands of classes
at all levels. Whether you're an artist,
freelancer, entrepreneur, or just a
person trying not to unravel, Skillshare
helps you tap into creativity that fuels
long-term clarity, balance, growth, and
success. Now, on Skillshare, I became a
member because I wanted to learn to
become more productive and to get a bit
of a handle on AI. This class here on
VO3 in Canva showed me how to make
cinematic AI videos using effective
prompting. I've used the skills provided
in this class to gain a good
understanding of how to prompt AI. It
also changed my mindset on AI, which I
now feel great about. It's hugely
improved my productivity and also my
understanding of AI. Now, the first 500
people that use the link in the
description or the QR code on the screen
will get a free month trial. I'm telling
you guys, using Skillshare is worth it.
So, go check it out right now. So, now
we've got all of the individual prompt
pieces. We can actually add these
together to create the perfect prompt to
generate the best video. Let's show you
how to do it. So, here are the prompt
ingredients added together into this
prompt. A lone grizzled fish in the
mid60s in a faded yellow slicker jacket
face weathered and focused deliberately
mends a heavy wet net with his scarred
hands. So, this whole first part here is
the subject and the action. So, we're
describing the subject in the scene and
then the action or what he's doing. Next
up, we're moving on to shot with a slow
continuous handheld tracking shot at
shoulder level with shallow depth of
field on the subject. Now, we're setting
the composition. We're also describing
what camera angle to really display this
in. Next up takes place on a fogdrenched
deck of a rusty troller in the middle of
a choppy pre-dawn sea with sea spray
hitting the lens. So this is the
environment and we're describing the
environment so that we can really paint
the picture or in this case create the
video. Here we have style. We're
describing how we want the style of the
video to look. So ultra realistic
cinematic portrait. And then let's go on
to really mention the color grade. So
the color of the scene, moody teal and
orange color grade with some harsh rim
lighting. So, we've set the whole scene
and we've gone through every part of the
prompt formula. But one thing we haven't
discussed and this is so important is to
add in an audio prompt as well. So,
visually bringing the scene to life is
so important. But if you don't also tap
in to people's hearing so that they can
hear things going on in the scene as
well, then your video is not going to
have nowhere near as much impact. So the
audio is the creek of the boat, rhythmic
thud of waves and wet slap of the net.
So let's have a look at the result.
Let's try this with a completely
different theme though to show you that
this will work across the board. So,
this one is a young woman, the 20ies,
with expressive wide eyes and a slight
confident grin pulls a sleek, futuristic
augmented reality headset down over her
eyes with a purposeful practiced motion.
This is the subject and this is the
action that the subject is doing with
the product. Next up, we're looking at
the aspect ratio, which is going to be a
medium shot with a fast, shaky, close
quarters dolly in on the subject's face.
So, this is saying what camera motion we
want to create when we generate the
video. Then, a bit of context, a busy
colorful calf filled with diffused
natural light and the soft chatter of
other patrons. So, this is saying that
the environment needs to be this
colorful calf and we need to add these
people or these patrons into the
background. Finally, we're looking at
style. We want this to be a modern
social media/tech ad. Shallow depth of
field. We're describing the background.
Clean, vibrant color grading. So, we've
now got the color and the real feel of
the scene. Then, of course, you have
audio. We want this clear, crisp ASMR
light click of the headset immediately
followed by an energetic bassheavy
electronic beat drop. So I understand
that this seems like a lot of things,
but you have to break this down. Each
prompt piece of the ingredient you need
to bring together and then you end up
with this whole prompt which is going to
work really well for us.
[Music]
So, there might feel like a lot to
remember, but if you stick to these five
ingredients, these five themes in your
prompt, you're going to get good
results. Now, you'll have to practice
though because the more detailed you are
with your describing of things, the
better result you're going to get. So,
don't get discouraged if you start doing
this and your results aren't great. Just
try and be specific. Practice using
details and the more you practice, the
better you'll get. I hope you've enjoyed
the video. In the next video, I'm going
to show you how to do start frame to end
frame. And this is a more advanced
technique where you can create whole
stories and link different video clips
together to create short films. This is
a very powerful technique. It's going to
be more involved and I'm going to spend
a little bit more time in the next video
showing you how to do it. If that sounds
like something you'd like to learn to
do, make sure you hit subscribe. And if
you've enjoyed the video, give me a
like. Any questions you've got, drop
them in the comments section. Whatever
you do for the rest of the day, guys,
make sure it's a good and I'll see you
in the next video.